une cinquantaine de personnes dont la
plupart ne souhaite pas être filmée par
nos caméras
il est 20 heures ils sont venus chercher
leur panier repas
nous ne sommes pas aux restos du coeur
ni à la banque alimentaire ceux ci sont
étudiants et bénéficie de l'aide de
l'association les halles de rabelais
deux fois ça doit prendre deux fois on
donne beaucoup ça à peine qu'elle avait
connu des problèmes dans du riz des
pâtes ou encore du café les paniers sont
constitués selon les goûts du
bénéficiaire
mais les halles de rabelais ce n'est pas
que de la distribution alimentaire c'est
également du soutien et du dialogue
mais c'est d'échanger ce possible avec
les étudiants de les connaître un peu on
n'est pas seulement dans une relation
l'étudiant vient et on lui donne à
manger à des denrées il s'en va donc on
essaye de discuter avec lui pour le
connaître un peu mieux et en fait les
nous comme ils reviennent y sont
satisfait de ce qu'on leur propose pour
pouvoir assurer ses distributions toutes
les deux semaines les halles font appel
à la générosité étudiante plusieurs fois
dans l'année sur les différents campus
tourangeau je pense que la solidarité
étudiants à étudiants c'est quelque
chose de très important parce que
c'est ça qui va nous faire réagir plus
parce qu'on se sent plus concerné parce
que ça peut être notre ami qu'on est
dans ce sens ça quand on vit bien et
qu'on a de l'argent quand on est parent
nous aide
on se dit que ça en fait un peu
attention à ce qu'on dépense mais on se
retrouve pas comme d'autres personnes
que personnel dès qu'ils doivent tous
les jours comptés ce qu'elle mangeait
faire attention à ce qu'elles dépensent
les bénévoles souhaitent à présent
pérenniser et développer leur
association
l'idée serait de créer une épicerie
sociale dans laquelle les étudiants
pourraient venir faire leur choix dans
les différents rayons